Intro
Movies may get most of the attention when
it comes to easter eggs, hidden details, or
secret messages from the filmmakers, but they're
not alone.
It may be harder to spot them in television
shows, but make no mistake: the minds behind
some of your favorite shows spend just as
much time planting secret nods, clues, or
details for fans to search for on repeat viewings.
Here are 10 Amazing TV Show Easter Eggs You
Probably Missed.
The Flash
Comic book easter eggs are doled out every
episode, but one rose above all others.
In the original comics, the crossover of both
Flashes - Barry Allen and Jay Garrick - was
teased with iconic cover art featuring both
rushing to the rescue.
So when both appeared on the TV show, they
recreated the moment perfectly - down to the
well-placed bricks.
And not a single comic fan could have missed
it.
Community
The show may be famous for its inside jokes
and subtle gags, but one actually took place
on another TV show - on another network.
When Abed tells Jeff a tragic story about
appearing as an extra on Cougar Town, the
joke works on its own But if fans actually
tuned in to the ABC comedy two months later,
they could have seen it happen for themselves.
How I Met Your Mother
The show packed more than a few surprises,
but none was more tragic than a character's
death in season 6 - a shock to even the cast.
But it wasn't as much of a twist for those
who spotted the numbers 50 and 49 early in
the episode - kicking off a countdown through
the entire running time, meant to clue fans
in that something big was about to happen.
If they didn't catch it the first time, it's
hard to miss the second.
Fringe
The sci-fi series was famous for featuring
a mystery "Observer" in the background of
every episode, but they also featured clear
hints at the next story the team tackled.
Like when a bit of graffiti reading "Brain
Freeze" hinted at the next episode's villain
freezing victims' brains.. which included
a book by "S. Pores" - the spores from the
next episode - and so on, and so on, you get
the idea.
It's Always Sunny
No matter how pointless a secret you bury
in your show, someone will find it.
Like when the end credits for It's Always
Sunny featured three of the cast with initials
reversed, and random noises.
Someone took the hint and reverses the audio,
getting a clear message.
But they kept the tradition alive, even though
the messages were basically nonsense.
Arrested Development
The writers got plenty of mileage out of Michael
Cera's character sharing a name with famous
singer George Michael, but got even deeper
into the joke in Season 4.
When the boy finally decides he's had enough
teasing due to the star's... criminal history
(tired of being compared), he decides to change
his name "George Ma--...haris" - another actor
charged with the same crime in 1974.
The other man involved was the totally-his-real-name
Perfecto Telles... who began dating his cousin
the episode before.
Homeland
A secret from fans is one thing, but what
about a secret from the cast and crew?
When the makers of Homeland called on artists
to decorate their sets with Arabic graffiti
- to really make it seem like a Syrian refugee
camp - they didn't miss the opportunity.
Believing the show to reinforce negative stereotypes
about terrorist groups, the artists spraypainted
phrases like "Homeland is racist" or "there
is no Homeland" instead.
Scrubs
There weren't many appearances from J.D.'s
father, played by the late John Ritter, and
it's mainly because the actor got a more demanding
role on 8 Simple Rules around the same time.
Which makes it even better when you realize
that J.D.'s flashback scene is actually SET
in the living room from that other TV show.
It was clearly to save time, but fans have
another theory: J.D.'s dad wasn't around because
he was actually living with his OTHER family.
Tragic.
Game of Thrones
When Arya visits a stage production of King
Joffrey's death, fans get to see the events
of the show's early seasons re-enacted.
But they also get a nod to the future, when
the actress playing Cersei claims that "I
feel the winds of winter as they lick across
the land" If the words ring a bell, they should:
it's a tease of George R.R. Martin's next
book "The Winds of Winter".
There's another Game of Thrones secret, but
be warned: SPOILERS AHEAD.
The huge-but-simple servant Hodor became a
fan favorite carrying Bran Stark every step
of his journey, and he met an end that broke
every fan's heart, "holding the door" after
helping the boy escape down a massive corridor.
It was Hodor's last scene - and it ties back
to his first one, when he gets an order in
the show's fourth episode.
The writers didn't know it at the time, but
he would do just that as his last sacrifice.
Those are some of our favorite hidden easter
eggs and secret messages in hit TV shows,
but which ones did we miss?
Let us know in the comments, and don't forget
to subscribe for more videos like this one!